[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
the murder of nipsy hustle march 31st
2019
at about 3 20
in the afternoon there was an explosion
of violence eric ronald holder jr shot
and killed nixie hustle opening
statements are presented in the trial of
eric holder plus a civil trial over a
florida dog who was shot and killed is
the image of her death burned in your
memory forever yes candy the dog's owner
takes the stand and danielle redlich's
trial for the murder of her husband
michael redlich bled out within five to
six minutes is that correct that's what
i understood why this rebuttal witness
testimony is so important to the case
but first a lot of amber's story didn't
add up and the majority of the jury felt
she was more the aggressor hear from a
johnny depp amber heard juror for the
first time lawn crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer we're
getting word from a juror for the first
time since the monumental verdict was
handed down in the johnny depp versus
amber her trial millions of viewers
watched the verdict handed down right
here on law and crime network and the
capital gavel coverage of the trial
before that actor johnny depp sued
ex-wife amber heard for 50 million
dollars arguing her defamed him in her
2018 washington post op-ed about
domestic abuse hurd fired back with a
hundred million dollar counter suit
doubling down on abuse claims after
weeks of testimony including from both
depp and heard the jury awarded depp 10
million dollars in compensatory damages
and 5 million in punitive damages heard
also won part of her counter suit when
she was awarded two million dollars in
compensatory damages and nothing for
punitive damages over comments made by
depp's attorney adam waldman
for the first time since the verdict a
juror gives his take on the trial in an
exclusive interview with abc news the
juror's face and voice were not shown
but instead quotes from his interview
were outlined the male jurors said he
felt deaf was more credible than heard
and though the relationship may have
been toxic on both ends heard's claims
did not have enough support
the crying the facial expressions that
she had the staring at the jury all of
us were very uncomfortable she would
answer one question and she would be
crying and two seconds later she would
turn ice cold some of us use the
expression crocodile tears he said
ultimately what i think is truthful was
that they were both abusive to each
other i don't think that makes either of
them right or wrong but to rise to the
level of what she was claiming there
wasn't enough or any evidence that
really supported what she was saying
later in this segment law and crime
founder dan abrams commented on the
jurors interview saying it appeared as
though her testimony was rehearsed
i said there's a danger if she's looking
at the jurors too much that could be a
problem it can seem like she's acting
like it's over rehearsed because yes a
lawyer will tell a client try and make
sure you look over at the jury make sure
that you recognize them but i thought
she was doing it too much every question
she was asked she would literally she
would pause she would turn over to the
jury and she'd begin her answer and it's
clear that that at least this juror felt
that that was rehearsed
joining us today is texas plaintiff
attorney catherine lizardo and co-host
terry austin katherine let's start with
you uh when we're talking about this
case
what was your reaction to amber heard's
testimony and how that played out
my reaction there is i i said repeatedly
that when i was watching her testify the
moment she stepped off the stand i think
she already lost the case because of her
credibility factor when she testified we
already saw johnny depp and after he got
off the stand i mentioned that i think
he already won the court of public
opinion and that's true in the social
media sense but amber heard the way she
testified did not come across as
credible and as what the juror was
saying she kept them looking at them in
a very unusual weird way very unnatural
the way you would speak it's almost
condescending at some point how she was
just staring at them and telling them
her story so with this juror's comment
it shows that that didn't work out now
terry you've been saying this since day
one in terms of her inflection and the
way that she's been acting
what did you think about her comments
and dan abrams as well
you know what there are three scenarios
to prepping a witness you can be
over-rehearsed you can be under-prepped
or you can be well-prepared this is
definitely an example of where she was
over-rehearsed and i get it she is an
actor it was probably hard for the
lawyers to keep the acting from coming
into the testimony but it was way too
much and one of the other things that
the attorneys should have done is
listened to what she said when they were
prepping her if it did not sound
credible then they need to fix that and
here they allowed her to get on that
stand to be over rehearsed and to say
things that the jury was never going to
believe
all right it seems like the jury has
spoken at least one in some anonymity
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily the plaintiff takes the
stand in florida's candy the dog civil
tribe but first closing arguments inch
closer in the case of danielle redlich
hear from a rebuttal witness after this
[Music]
welcome back both sides rest in a case
of florida versus danielle redlich the
woman accused of murdering her stepdad
turned husband
redlick is charged with second-degree
murder and evidence tampering for the
murder of her husband michael redlich
redlich claims she killed him in
self-defense when she stabbed him in
2019. the two had been married for
nearly 20 years and had two children
together defense attorneys say the
couple's relationship had a history of
abuse and cheating the couple had also
reportedly filed for divorce by the time
of michael's death 911 calls reveal
redlick initially told dispatchers that
michael stabbed himself and had a heart
attack investigators say she waited
several hours before calling for help
the night of his death as part of its
rebuttal the state called the case's
lead detective whose testimony differed
from the medical examiners
you attended the autopsy of michael
redlich in this case is that right
that's correct
and you spoke with dr zado zadovich
that's correct and she was the medical
examiner who conducted the autopsy of
michael redlick yes that's correct and
you had a conversation with dr zadovich
didn't you yes and she told you that
michael redlich bled out within five to
six minutes is that correct that's what
i understood that he died within five to
six minutes of the stab wound is that
correct
that's what i understood
on the next episode of law and crime
daily we'll break down closing arguments
from both sides
terry why is it so important that the
lead detective testified saying michael
redlich died within six minutes
especially when it didn't seem to match
up with the medical examiner's testimony
credibility is everything in any trial
and here the jury instructions actually
said if there's a prior inconsistent
statement then the jury can consider
that and it was really important that
lead detective talk about the fact that
the medical examiner first told her
that in fact he bled out in five to six
minutes that's critical because that
means that we know that the defendant
didn't just wait around until he passed
that it was five or six minutes and then
when the medical examiner got on the
stand she really tried to backtrack and
she said well you have to observe so it
was critical that that information got
in and kudos to the defense for getting
that in there for having that detective
admit that yeah it's gonna cause a
little confusion for the jury there and
maybe a little reasonable doubt
catherine what did the lead detective
give the prosecution and defense to
argue in their summation and who had
more to use based on this testimony
the defense definitely has more to use
in this testimony because then they can
question as terry mentioned the
credibility of the witnesses that that
the state put on what's interesting too
in here is when we were uh seeing how
the prosecution where was questioning uh
daniel redlich he was very intimidating
and almost uh over the top in terms of
using the juror in amber hurt's case uh
when the juror mentioned that amber
heard's legal team was sharp on the
elbow here the prosecutor when he was
questioning uh daniel redling he even
had his arm on his side
and towering over her seems like it and
did not look appropriate in terms of
being too condescending so i think that
the defense will definitely use that a
lot as well in addition to the lead
detective absolutely there's a reason
why a lot of people say camille vasquez
cross-examining amber heard it made a
lot more sense than ben chu and that's i
think the point that you're making
and in jacksonville florida defending
alan wade offers an emotional apology at
his resentencing trial for his
involvement in the murder which happened
more than a decade ago wade along with
three others michael james jackson
tiffany cole and bruce nixon were
convicted in 2008 for their involvement
in the 2005 murder of reggie and carol
sumner a couple who were buried alive
after being robbed a jury found the four
guilty of digging a hole in a remote
wooded area in georgia before kidnapping
the sumners stealing from the couple's
home then forcing them into the trunk of
their own car they forced the summoners
to share bank account information before
burying them alive three of the four
were given the death penalty wade and
jackson are being re-sentenced
separately after a change in florida law
which requires a unanimous jury decision
for the death penalty wade took the
stand on wednesday not for questioning
by attorneys but to give an apology to
the family of the victims and his own
nothing i say here today is
meant to justify excuse or
defend my cowardly crimes
reggie and carol
if there's a window or
a connection to the afterlife or some
sort of cosmic consciousness
and i know you can see
it's tremendous
regret
and shame
in my heart
coming up on law and crime daily opening
statements are presented as nipsy
hustle's accused murder stands trump
plus candy the dog's owner takes the
stand to describe the emotional moment
when his dog was shot and killed
[Music]
welcome back a dog's owner takes the
stand in a civil trial out of florida as
he works to bring justice for the death
of his beloved companion
a dog owner rodney jacobson filed a
civil suit against zachary dieterle
saying dieterly wrongly shot his dog
candy it happened on dieterley's
father's property back in 2016. jacobson
who had permission to store his boat on
the property was cleaning it candy was
off leash when she approached dearly he
says the dog was in an attack stance
after that dealey pulled out his
revolver and shot the dog twice the
sarasota county sheriff's office says
deedley was not charged because he had a
permit to carry the weapon they say he
was
he was also within his right to use
deadly force because he feared for his
life jacobson says kenny had no history
of aggression and was only barking at
deterly because she didn't recognize him
on thursday jacobson took the stand he
testified what happened the night candy
was killed
i heard
two gunshots
and
looked over at mr diesel and he had a
revolver in his hand
and he had fired two shots at candy
i was in disbelief i said did you just
shoot my dog my dog and he said damn
right i did and i do it again how did
you find candy
well i tried i followed
her i saw where she was running towards
the boat so i
ran after her
and um
when i got closer to the boat on the
dock and then on the gunnel of the boat
and then in the cabin of the boat where
she ended up there were you know trail
of blood were you in fear during that
situation
it wasn't feared that that he had not
put his gun down and was still
brandishing it around
well
while
i was going after her candy
and but were you fearful during when he
was firing the weapon that it could have
been turned on you yeah
terry jacobson sued for intentional
infliction of emotional distress what
kind of damages can he recover under
that cause of action
you know what this is one of my favorite
causes of action under florida law you
have to prove four things that it's
deliberate it's outrageous the conduct
caused the emotional distress and the
distress was severe so you have to
demonstrate those things and you do that
by asking whether or not he sought
medical treatment whether or not any of
his relationships suffered that's why
you saw the plaintiff asking all of
those questions to the individual on the
stand to the plaintiff on the stand and
so he answered those questions the jury
can then determine what are your actual
damages did you have to pay for this did
you have to pay for that and also the
jury can give you an award for that
emotional distress really the attorney
should try to set a number but if you
don't the jury can set a number
themselves so it's a really broad
difficult one to prove but a broad cause
of action yeah typical to prove any dog
owner will say the same what number do
you put on a beloved four-legged
companion such as uh candy but catherine
jacobson hopes that winning this case
brings about criminal charges but is
that likely and how would that work
not necessarily because the burden of
proof for criminal cases are much higher
as we know as opposed to civil cases and
so winning here in the civil case will
not automatically
result in in criminal charges now what
could happen though is the evidence that
have been presented in the civil trial
they can use that for the criminal case
i know that there were no criminal
charges filed against uh dieter lee for
shooting the dog because they the
officers felt that he was within his
rights to shoot the dog because the he
was on the prop the dog was on the
property and and also he said he feared
for his life now what comes out in the
civil trial will definitely be critical
if there's going to be a future criminal
charge case all right we'll see how this
case continues and how it's resolved in
the end and maybe it does maybe it
doesn't go to that next level of a
criminal case when we come back the
murder of nipsy hustle opening
statements are presented as eric holder
jr stands trial for the murder
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
opening statements are presented in the
long-awaited california murder trial of
eric holder jr a man charged with murder
in the death of rapper nipsey hussell
prosecutors say nipsy hustle was gunned
down by holder outside the rapper's los
angeles clothing store in march 2019. in
addition to his music career nipsey
husso was reportedly dedicated to
supporting youth and the community where
he grew up the same community where he
died after three years of delays holder
is facing a jury for the facing a jury
for the first time on charges of first
degree murder two counts of attempted
murder and assault with a deadly weapon
police say a dispute broke out between
the two men before holder left the store
then returned with two firearms a
medical examiner found nipsey hussell
was shot at least 10 times with the
bullets piercing his lungs and severing
his spinal cord during opening
statements wednesday prosecutors told
jurors nipsey hussell was killed in a
calculated and premeditated attack
jurors saw a video showing the last
seconds of nipsy hustle's life
march 31st
2019
at about 3 20
in the afternoon there was an explosion
of violence
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
at that place and at that time
the world lost
hermes joseph ascadon
better known to the world is missy
eric holder is shooting from a
40 caliber semi-automatic handgun
and a revolver
he fires at least 10
possibly 11 shots
after he's done shooting
walks over
he kicks him in the head
and then he runs back toward the out
holder's defense attorney says his
client doesn't deny shooting nipsy
hustle only that it was not a
premeditated attack
on march 31st 2019
eric ronald holder jr shot and killed
nymphs hustle a bullet accidentally hit
mr latham
and
uh mr villanueva may have been grazed
we're not sure
and the provocative act in this case was
that
dipsy hustle had made an accusation
against mr holder that he was a snitch
that so inflamed and enraged
mr holder the evidence will show that
without thinking and a few minutes later
a mere nine minutes or so later mr
holder returned and shot
mr basketball
all right so we heard it there defense
attorney doesn't seem too confident in
his own opening statements but let's
kind of dissect it there catherine
holder's defense offenses saying this
isn't premeditated because this nine
minutes wasn't enough of a cooling off
period and he was still in the heat of
passion a legal term uh trying to drop
this down from murder to manslaughter
but does that make sense
you know when he's trying to argue the
nine minutes that's what we call a
question of back
as to looking at other cases what has
happened what has been concluded as to
whether nine minutes is enough as a
cooling of period for premeditated but
if you think about it using your common
sense nine minutes is a long time and
one way to do that is take out your your
watch and really put that in a timer for
nine minutes that's a long time when we
are on break here for the show that's
about three minutes and it feels like a
long time now multiply that you know by
three that's
as you can imagine you will feel the
length of time also the key there is he
left
to get guns and then come back and shoot
him the act of actually leaving and
going through that exact motion of
getting the guns coming back and
shooting him that will definitely be
played out here step by step during uh
any examination of the shooter here yeah
supposedly he also left and finished
some chili fries i mean you sit down to
eat chili fries that's enough time to
cool down in my mind so we'll see how
that plays out when the test when it
comes out but terry nipsey hussle and
holder have ties or alleged ties to the
crips and the defense is saying that in
gang culture uh being called a snitch is
enough for a heat of passion defense how
much of gang life is going to be brought
into this trial and is that believable
you know i think a lot of gang life will
be brought into this trial i hope not
though because that's not what this
trial is about as catherine said it's
all about whether or not he came back it
was premeditated he knew what he was
going to do he got those guns so i hope
the gang doesn't come into it we'll see
how it plays out thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you